over the last 10 years we've built an
incredible ecosystem together Android
walks on devices of all sizes and shapes
in every country play has become one of
the largest app distribution stores in
the world and all of you have built
amazing apps and games that entertain
educate and help people to get stuff
done along the way we have partnered
together to deal with constant change
and seize opportunities we have entered
new markets figured out new business
models like subscription figured out how
to have better quality apps and delight
more users we continue to evolve a
platform based on your feedback at any
given point in time we have about a half
a dozen or more EAPs going thank you for
participating in them some of them never
see the light of the day and others
become enormous global programs such as
pre-reg which started with a tiny pilot
and now is available for all developers
on the Play console so building an
ecosystem is a collaborative process so
we are really grateful for what you do
with us and we listen to you many of the
updates you will hear today come
directly from the feedback you have
given us you told us my app is so big I
can't add more features please give me
data insights to improve my app or game
and help me have customized detailed
pages when my users come to look for my
app or game my colleagues from product
and engineering will give you more
details on what we have built and our
focus is to make sure we help you build
great apps and successful
businesses speaking of successful
businesses one of the topic that has
come up a lot
whenever I have spoken with you guys
recently is the topic of sustainable
growth you have told us that you want to
build relationships with your users for
years not weeks or months game
developers are building IP and story
lines that have longevity and using
things like live ops and community
building to have users use their games
for the long run ELQ upon an end who's
the CEO of supercell envisions as games
to be used for 15 plus years
app developers are also investing in
this they're looking at subscriptions as
a way to continually give value to the
users and keep them in the long run on
Play we are also focused on having happy
users who stay with us for a long run
and for us that means and renewed focus
on platform safety and user trust users
have told us that they want to make sure
that there is transparency and control
over how their sensitive data is being
used and we are listening to them as you
heard yesterday in queue we are giving
users more control about how their data
can be used but this location access or
which apps can do background processing
on play we are also strengthening our
policies to end further enhance safety
for users and build platform trust we
have always encouraged all of you to
make sure that you only use the
permissions that you absolutely need
however our guidelines haven't always
been consistent nor has the enforcement
been consistent so over the last year we
started to take a few more steps we
started to make changes to things like
SMS and call log permissions restricting
access to only those use cases which we
believed were valid for example a
a user picks your messaging app as their
default messaging app we understood that
this would mean that some of the
features that you have built even the
ones that users value may not be
available once these changes were put
into motion and we've worked with you to
find alternatives I am very happy to
announce here that based on those
changes we have reduced apps that get
access to SMS and call log by 98% and in
doing so we have managed to get most
people to have some other way of
accessing the same functionality or
eliminate minor functionality there are
more changes coming in these changes we
are going to think about all the stuff
that's happening on queue and look about
what those changes we need to do on Play
to safeguard more apps and games as
especially those that are targeting
families as we make those changes we
will continue to listen to you so you
told us that our change process the
input form the appeals process the
actions you need to take has room for
improvement and we hear you so here's my
commitment to you today we will be more
transparent about the changes we will
make the actions you need to take and we
will give you sufficient time to make
those changes and here's my ask of you
please play attention to our comms they
will be on your play console emails
blogs and prioritize these changes
together we will build an ecosystem
which businesses are sustainable and
users are happy and stay for the long
run so now let's talk about what's new
so I have my colleagues coming up to
give you details Cobie will come up and
talk about ways to develop apps to reach
lots of users using features such such
as Android app bundles and plays dynamic
delivery
and then milena will come in and talk
about release tools that help you
iterate quickly pre-release and then
think about tracking performance and
improving your app post-launch and then
we have a rush coming in and talking
about the many tools we have built to
grow your business sustainably through
things like marketing and monetization
so without further ado put your hands
together to welcome Kobi Glick
thanks for anima hi everyone I'm Kobi
from the Play team I want to show you
how to use our platform to reach more
users and grow your business Google Play
has always focused on developer needs
and those needs didn't change that much
since we launched play a few years ago
you need to build an app deliver it to
users and grow your business this
includes driving discovery engagement
monetization and analyzing your app
performance but why your basic needs
didn't change that much Google Play has
gotten much much bigger play now serves
a tremendous number of users all over
the world users coming from different
cultures speaking different languages
using different devices and connectivity
profiles and this created new challenges
and opportunities and to open the door
for this new business opportunity you
need to tackle some more complex
business needs for example how do you
reach users in emerging markets how do
you communicate to those users how do
you communicate to those users to your
store listing page and Google Play how
do you build your app with storage and
data costs in mind so as we've grown we
introduced a number of tools and
features to help you tackle those new
business needs in this talk we're going
to show you a bunch of features we're
launching today to help you develop
release and grow your apps and games on
Google Play let's start with development
when you think about the Playstore you
typically think about the storefront but
plays more than that behind the scenes
we're doing a lot to keep you apps and
games up to date and your business
running and I want to give you some
context about the scale we're dealing
with every month we send to exabytes of
app installs and updates this is a huge
amount of data and in fact the raw data
size is five exabytes but thanks to
place patching and compression we're
able to cut down the download size for
users by sixty percent this is not only
great for users but also for you since
it makes your app delivery more
efficient and reliable and that's not
the only thing we're doing to make your
app development more efficient last year
we introduced a change to the apk format
you've been using for the first 10 years
on Android we told you why we think it's
a time for a change why because the apk
is inefficient security could be better
and it's built for monolithic apps with
the apk devices get code and resources
they don't need if you ever lose or
compromise your signing key you need to
abandon your app and create a new
listing and you always have to ship each
one of your features to all your users
so last year we introduced androids new
publishing format the Android app bundle
and a completely new dynamic delivery
framework on Google Play the app bundle
is efficient secure and enables modular
apps and the momentum we've seen is
incredible there are now over 80,000
apps and games that switch to a bundle
in production on Google Play with an
average size reduction of 20% as a
result of this I savings app switching
to the bundle see up to 11% install
uplift let's take a look at some of the
apps who switch with the app bundle and
their site savings you can see apps like
Twitter we're part of our early access
developer program last year and you can
see apps like
PayPal tinder and clash of clans by
supercell who switched to the bundle
earlier this year and more Google Apps
are switching to photos home and duo all
now use our bundles in production on
Google Play with some very significant
size savings like you can see right here
to help you track an optimize your app
size today we're launching a new section
of android vitals with new metrics
reporting and guidance in this area you
will be able to see both the download
size of your app as well as the size of
your app right after the install we will
show you how your app size changes over
time and provide you information on how
to further reduce it so that's the
efficiency aspect of the app bundle
now let's talk about the security aspect
your signing key is now more secure
because Google Play holds a copy and
protects it from loss and today we're
launching a new feature that allows you
to upgrade the cryptographic strengths
of your signing key for new installs and
their updates some apps on Google Play
signed with old signing keys and our new
feature is the only backward compatible
way to increase their strength and it's
only available when you enrolled into
app signing by Google Play finally let's
talk about the modularity aspect the app
bundle
introduces modularization through
dynamic feature modules
this increases engineering velocity
because teams can design build and
maintain features independently Facebook
for example has found success using
dynamic features to implement
functionality that is relatively
separate than the rest of the app
they're then adding those features to
the main app without increasing its base
install size dynamic features allow you
to customize when in to whom you deliver
specific functionality today we're
announcing that dynamic features are
coming out of beta and are now available
to all of you including some new
delivery options with dynamic features
you can deliver functionality on demand
for example
Redbus is an app that allows users buy
bus tickets the use dynamic feature is
to test a new business idea allowing
enterprise consumers to book tickets for
events dynamic features are perfect for
this use case because Red Bus is able to
target specific audience and determine
the product market fit for this new line
of business the ability to deliver this
feature only to users who want them
allows Red Bus to keep their app size
small at the point of install and
provide a more customized experience to
users who are interested in this
additional functionality today we're
also introducing the option to deliver
features conditionally at the time of
install this means you can control which
parts of your app would be delivered to
users based on the country or the
features of their device for example if
you have an AR feature you can decide to
install it only on AR capable devices as
you see here you can define a feature
module as conditional with a very simple
change to your app manifest you can also
instant enable modules to offer instant
experiences the Android app bundle now
fully supports instant apps so you can
build and publish a single artifact for
both your instant apps and installed
experiences during our beta program we
had many developers who implemented some
very cool use cases with dynamic
features for example like you've seen in
the video earlier Netflix is now
delivering their customer support
functionality to their users as a
dynamic feature
in production this means that only users
that need to call for support actually
need to download this feature by using
the app bundle and dynamic delivery
features such as this Netflix were able
to reduce the download size of their app
by 33% from 23 megabyte to 15 megabytes
and they're just getting started so
switch to the a bundle for the size
savings and stay for the customizable
delivery options we're big believers in
app modularity we think this is the
future of apps
in our dynamic framework paves the way
to that future and there's one more
thing we're launching as part of our
dynamic framework today the in-app
updates
API is now available to all of you we
know that sometimes it's really
important for you to get your users on
the latest version of your app we've
seen how some developers implemented
this through blocking screens or even
send emails to their users so one of
your top requests from Google Play was
that we allow you to update users that
are on an old version and today we're
excited to make it happen our new API
allows you to get users to update
without ever leaving your app here's the
popular Indian food delivery app swiggy
using the flexible update flow to
provide a user experience that matches
their look and feel you can also use the
immediate flow for a simpler integration
that handles every aspect of the update
flow across all our early access
partners we've seen a median user
acceptance rate of 50% for such in-app
updates so that's it for the development
section and now Molina will tell you
about releasing your app and analyzing
its performance thank you
thanks Kobi release your app or an
update is the most critical activity you
can do in the play console it's how you
actually deliver all the great things
you build to your users and every month
more than 750,000 apks gets rolled out
to play consoles that represents more
than half a million app makers like
yourselves excited to be pushing their
latest and greatest changes to their
user audience and again it started
simple release a single apk to
production which we released with the
very first version of android market
publisher site back in 2009 but as
Android apps got more traction the need
to test your app before releasing it
became more important play led the
mobile developer market in the sense and
launched beta testing and staged
rollouts in 2013 we're proud to say we
were the first introduce the tools which
are now the established best practice
for the successful mobile developers in
2016 play introduced open beta allowing
you to massively scale beat the testing
even before public launch of your app
this has become a super popular choice
for leading app developers like whatsapp
who now have 25 million open beta
testers you then told us you wanted more
tools to further ensure your apps are
ready to launch so last year we launched
internal testing to help you create
faster test releases now more than
150,000 apps use internal testing tracks
we also launched multiple closed testing
tracks to help you vet different feature
releases with different groups of
testers for example different teams
within your company to date 35000 apps
have used this feature and this year
we're pushing the envelope even further
you told us that it's sometimes painful
to have to create a release just if you
want to share a test build with the
member of your QA team or your product
manager so today we're launching
internal app sharing this new feature
allows you to share test builds with
your team in a matter of seconds just
drag and drop in a bundle and get a
shareable URL to install your test
version you don't need to worry about
version code signing keys or most other
validations that you need to think about
when you're launching your production
release we believe this combination of
speedy upload and fully featured play
distribution will enable you to iterate
faster and better
even as the ecosystem grows more complex
this also addresses the biggest feature
request that we've heard from you which
was to provide Bethel a better app
bundle testing integration into your
work clothes now you can simply upload
your bundle get a shareable URL and use
this URL to download the apk that are
then dynamically delivered by play ok so
now that you released your app let's
talk about how you analyze its health
and performance here we first started
with a simple list of crash reports
which was helpful but not actionable
enough every app crashes sometimes the
important question is is your app
actually doing well so a couple of years
ago we launched Android vitals vitals
include 15 engineering metrics across 5
performance areas that represent the
things users care about the most
they represent the performance and
quality of your app as experienced on
real devices in the hands of real users
in the real world today over 100,000
developers use android vitals including
60% of top 1,000 it's an important tool
to help you focus your improvements
exactly where you have the biggest
opportunities did you know that 42% of
one star reviews mentioned stability or
bugs our performance matters and Android
vitals can help you address it last year
we launched category benchmarks to show
you how your app performs against other
apps in your
beggary but you told us those benchmarks
were too broad to yield meaningful
results we thought about this feedback a
lot and spent a long time trying to work
out a solution that works for everyone
on the one hand we know we're in a
unique position to share the data across
the ecosystems which you can't get
anywhere else but on the other hand we
also need to protect the privacy of
individual businesses that we serve so
how could we bridge this gap today we're
pleased to announce developer selected
peer benchmarks for Android vitals you
can now select a team of eight to twelve
peers to compare your app to then see
the median value for the peer as well as
the difference between your app and your
peers and it searches for vitals we
build a new benchmarks platform in a
fully generic way so over the next few
months you'll be able to see the
benchmark value for almost any metric in
the console for public metrics like app
rating you can see benchmarks for the
peer set you've manually selected and
for business sensitive metrics like
conversion rate you can compare your app
to an auto-generated peer set of around
100 most similar apps so now you can
finally know if your numbers are good
and whether you're keeping up with your
peers for example you'll be able to see
if your uninstall rate is higher than
your peers then compare how you're doing
on the common causes of retention issues
like crash rate or apk size we're super
excited to see how you use this data to
get ahead ok let's talk some more about
business performance reports here we
also started with simple basic install
metrics then over the years expanded to
specialized reports to give you more
critical insights into your revenue and
acquisition we even added hour-by-hour
reporting for you to track immediate
effects of your updates today we're
announcing the biggest change the core
metrics since we started the data
reporting in the console our teams have
been working for almost a year to
redefine and Rebbie
these metrics from the ground up all to
enable you to answer some of the most
critical business questions that you
have for example how many new users you
acquired or how many existing users you
lost in the past 30 days the new metrics
are broader and more accurate for
example you'll now be able to see
reporting on returning users which is
critical for understanding your total
acquisition you can query the
performance by acquisition channels that
only play has an insight into for
example peer-to-peer sharing and app
pre-installed and you can reliably
aggregate and dedupe all of this over
periods from hours to quarters our main
focus was to give you the right data but
all in all this new launch also offers
ten times more metrics and variations
than you currently have access to and to
make data consumption easier we've
updated the statistics page to
automatically perform common analysis
like benchmarking growth rates and
performing automatic period and period
charting so to recap new metrics will
give you insight into your apps
performance that you've never had before
and the new stats page will help you
find out what happened why it happened
and whether what happened was good or
not we're also making changes to another
key source of performance data your user
reviews many of you asked us to change
the way we calculate Google Playstore
rating to better reflect the current
quality of your app or game you told us
that you want a rating based on what
your app is today not what it was years
ago and we agree so today I'm happy to
announce that the average rating
calculation is changing instead of a
lifetime cumulative value your new
average will be recalculated to give
more weight to the most recent ratings
with this change your place the rating
will not only give users better
understanding of the current state of
your app it will also better reflect all
your hard work and improvements users
won't see the updated value in the Play
Store until August but you can preview
your new rating in the Play
today of course ratings are only half of
the feedback equation your users also
leave reviews every day
developers respond to more than hundred
thousand reviews into play console and
when they do we've seen that users react
very positively when receiving a reply
from developers users increase their
rating by 0.7 stars on average so in
addition to the ratings change we're
making it easier to respond to user
reviews build by Google research
suggested replies uses machine learning
to provide one touch smart responses for
easier text communication you may
already be familiar with this type of
feature from Gmail and messages but if
you're not it's very easy to use when
you go to reply to user review you can
see three suggested replies they have
been created automatically based on the
content of a user review and the way you
naturally communicate to your users you
can choose to send one as is you can
customize it for more personalization or
you can write in your reply from scratch
the choice is yours all these new
features I talked about were designed
with one thing in mind to help you
succeed by enabling you to release
faster measure your app health and
improve your performance and now rush
will tell you about what play does to
help your business grow thank you
[Applause]
thank you awesome thanks Melina
we've been focused on building tools to
help you grow your app retain users and
improve monetization every month over 2
billion users come to the Play Store to
discover new apps that's 2 billion users
waiting to discover your app and we want
to make sure you have the right tools
and the right support to reach every one
of them today I'm going to talk to you
about three key areas where Google Play
can help grow your business first
optimizing your store listing second
driving games discovery and third
improving monetization so let's dive in
with store listings back in 2015 we
launched store listing experiments
enabling you to a be test different
variants of your store listings page we
were excited to see how quickly
developers adopted this feature to test
everything from icons and screenshots to
titles and descriptions and we were even
more surprised to see developers hiring
dedicated teams to specifically focus on
App Store optimization your enthusiasm
and feedback in this area led us to
invest more and so recently we launched
custom listing pages with this
capability you now have the option of
having multiple unique listing pages in
production targetable to different
audiences like country over the holidays
reify a developer from india with the
cookbook app leveraged this country
targeting capability to tune their
feature graphic by country resulting in
a 17% increase to install conversion and
today I'm excited to announce that we're
taking this a step further with a new
early access program
custom listings buy install state with
this capability you now can target three
new audiences users who've never
installed your app users who've
uninstalled your app and users who
currently have your app installed we're
excited about this and if you're
interested in trying it out check out
the link also at GBC this year we
announced the general availability of
pre-registration support with
pre-registration you can now build hype
and excitement around your app or game
prior to launch
today we're adding two new features onto
this first you can now have custom
listings pages for the pre-registration
state and second are adding a new
feature we call pre-registration rewards
which now enables you to give users who
pre-register a special in-app gift Nexon
the creator of the game faith leveraged
this capability and saw that users who
were given a reward were 20% more likely
to revere attained at day 30 they also
saw a significant improvement in
conversion between people who
pre-registered and users who actually
installed the app when it was released
we're really excited about these
capabilities and to see how you use them
to tune your conversion funnel as always
please let us know if you have feedback
we'd like to know how to improve and one
last thing while we're on the topic of
that conversion funnel I wanted to make
a quick plug for app icons we announced
a new icon spec earlier this year and
we'd like everyone to update their icons
by June 24th the goal here is really to
provide a more clean and polished user
experience within the store for our
users for those of you who can't make
that date don't stress we have a great
legacy mode that keeps your icons
looking good until you have time to
update them okay with that let's switch
gears a little bit and talk about games
discovery so I thought it would be
interesting to give a little bit of
context as we've been thinking about
this space for a long time we had two
key insights as we were thinking about
how to evolve the discovery experience
of the store first we realized that most
of the discovery experience is centered
around a single piece of metadata your
app icon and while you all spend a lot
of time thinking about how to tune that
icon to communicate your brand the IP of
the game the category etc at the end of
the day there's a physical limit with
how much you can communicate with those
pixels the second realization we had was
that the deeper you go into the user
funnel the closer you get the user to
the actual experience of playing the
game the more compelling and rich that
content is enabling users to make
informed choices and as a result we
really tried to push for a more content
forward experience in the Play Store
drawing all of that great rich content
from the game your store listings page
and
indicating it all across the store and
you can see examples of this in
production today with things like
trailers and screenshots auto-playing
videos and events these formats are a
great way to attract new users and to be
eligible for them you just need to make
sure that you've done two things first
you need to make sure that you have at
least three sixteen by nine screenshots
uploaded to the developer console and
second you need to check that your
promotional video has monetization
disabled and is made public we also
launched Google Play Instant last year
with the goal of furthering this content
forward experience the goal here is
really to enable users to just jump in
and try the game out getting a quick
feel for it without having to commit to
installing or uninstalling and we've
seen massive growth in the adoption of
instant especially amongst our largest
most successful partners in the
ecosystem the number of instant games
has exploded hundreds of them in the
store actually and developers are
starting to see great uplift here game
developers are seeing install
conversions increased by up to 20% with
a great instant experience and this is
particularly useful for paid apps and
games where now you can enable try
before you buy functionality as a result
of this success we've expanded the
footprint of incident across the store
by syndicating the try Now button
everywhere and with the advent of the
app bundle and improved integration into
unity adopting instant is easier than
ever
lastly we've been focused on
monetization in the last year we
expanded our international footprint
especially in emerging markets we added
seller support to 31 new markets we
expanded our a wallet program to cover
14 countries and we added 20 new direct
carrier billing partnerships our direct
carrier billing footprint alone reaches
over 1.3 billion devices in the fleet
and that's just one of our forms of
payment we know that emerging markets
are a key area of growth for you all
which is why we're excited to announce
pending transactions this is a new class
of delayed form of payment like cash
bank transfer and direct debit
and for developers with subscription
businesses we're extremely excited about
our subscribe and install feature this
features a streamlined float that lets a
user sign up for a free trial and
install the app in the same simple flow
it's an early access right now and our
partners are seeing amazing results with
double-digit growth in the number of
paid subscribers all of these features
and more are only available with a new
version of the billing library and I do
mean an more there was a lot I didn't
have time to cover today so I highly
recommend checking out the deep dive the
what's new in Google Play billing
session later today and with that I'd
like to welcome purnama back to the
stage thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Josh wow that was a lot of
great stuff yes oh come on you can do
better than that we worked very hard for
an entire year we really really hope
that you will use these features to
develop apps that can reach even bigger
audiences and release them and track
them and grow them into sustainable
businesses I know it is a lot of
information so I want to share two
helpful resources behind me is a link to
a blog post which will recap all the
features we have talked about so please
take a look at the blog post I'll give
you a minute right and we have this
wonderful thing called the play Academy
where you can go and learn all details
of all these features learn how to use
them etc so please take a look at the
play Academy use it so there's a link to
play Academy here and finally as always
we sincerely hope you will let us know
once you've used it how these features
have helped you things we can improve
and we are here to listen
and do more with you together I want to
thank you on behalf of Coby Melina
a Russian myself and the entire play
team for your continued partnership I'm
excited about to see what you will do
with the features we shared with you
today and look forward to seeing you
next year have a wonderful eye o 2019
thank you very much
[Music]